[Music]
it's my speech there are others like it
but this is mine I wrote it myself
last night while screaming into an empty
bag of Doritos man how good was Matt
Damon as Supreme Court nominee Marin
County
Oh buzzed me crazy it was so good it was
the perfect choice to play yeah I mean
this show was a big hit
SNL got off to its best start in two
years and we found out how they pulled
off the damon surprise me tell you this
I'm gonna start at an 11:00
I'm gonna take it to about a 15 real
quick a source tells E team Matt arrived
in New York late on Saturday afternoon
and went straight to rehearsal for his
surprise appearance as the embattled
Cavanaugh and usually an optimist I'm a
keg is half-full kind of guy his look
was created just hours before the live
taping I like beer watching backstage
ariana grande our source says she kept
to herself and didn't show up with an
entourage
ariana was originally supposed to be
SNL's musical guest who dropped out
citing emotional reasons but her quicky
engagement to cast member Pete Davidson
was a running gag throughout the show
starting with host Adam drivers bottle
aw oh you don't want to hear about my
son no actually you're the one person
whose summer I really want to hear about
the prenup situation well obviously I
wanted one you know so god forbid god
forbid we split up and she takes half my
sneakers and here's something you didn't
see Kanye West who replaced Ariana going
on a political rant for several minutes
from the stage long after the show was
off the air our source tells us no one
an SNL told Kanye not to wear the mega
hat and that he was going around
backstage asking people if he should
white Kim Kardashian was also backstage
so was daughter North our source says
both seemed unfazed like Kanye's ran SNL
has another good lineup this coming
weekend aquafina is hosting of course
she is hot off of crazy rich Asians and
Travis Scott will perform you know he is
Kylie Jenner's baby daddy
[Music]